I'm in Romania in the mining village of
Russia Montana it's the plant site of
Europe's biggest gold mine international
investors are on the scent of billions
of euros worth of gold but resistance to
the project means the plans are on hold
my investigation start in the
Transylvanian city of cluj-napoca it's
one of the most well-off places in
Romania and I constantly come across
this slogan save Russia Montana it's a
symbol of the resistance movement
against gold mining in Romania and I've
been invited to the heart of the
resistance movement for activists like
to do abroad ASEAN saving the
environment is more important than
earning billions from gold there were
other campaigns that did not resist so
many years that did not make because if
you look at what we did we were always
one step in front of the company in
front of the politicians that supported
this this company
there are a lot more than 150 people
many of the protesters are young Romania
was once one of the most brutal Eastern
Bloc dictatorships but this is a
different generation to the one which
fought communism their fight is against
gold mining and for the environment
fellow activist Mihai got seen says this
is the most important civil movement
since the end of communism as a church
in spas it's asserted that the gore team
says that in the past 10 to 15 years
protest movements have lost all the
battles they fought with the corrupt
political class in Romania the success
of this movement has set a precedent and
that's given people confidence not only
with Russia Montana but with other
issues too - door is coming with me to
Russia Montana to explain the reason for
this grassroots movement we're heading
into the Carpathian Mountains before we
get to the village we pass a banner put
up by the investors who want to mine
gold here
the banner promises development in the
region Tudor sees that differently many
claims that the size of the project will
affect all of this region first of all
we have to understand that taking the
the forest out and the the the fertile
land
will reveal a lot of dust that is going
to be spread all around this area and
that dust is the reason to have small
even really radioactive particles part
of this is the big cyanide lake that
will have evaporations
and the gas that is going up into the
air will definitely affect the crops of
the people living in all of this area
cyanide is used around the world to
separate gold from the rock and there
are plans to use it in Russia Montana
these men are waiting to get down to
work they've been on the payroll here
for more than a decade but the investors
are still waiting for a government
permit before mining operations can
start if this mining the mining project
goes ahead what you see all of that
mountain there will become a huge hole
into the ground the Russian Montana Gold
Corporation wants to remove four peaks
here and extract one gram of gold from
every tonne of rock the company has paid
for numerous families to leave their
land over the past ten years but the
most stubborn won't go and Tudor has
brought me to see one of them will gain
dahveed he's an icon of the protest
movement and the best-known activist in
the village come on he says let's go to
see the cows we can talk in the shed
we're enemies he says we're at war it's
the relationship between an ordinary man
and a large company which wants to
trample on my rights in my own home
potentially like everywhere else in the
world where mining takes place the
investors want the locals to sell up
moon gain has a lot of land here land he
inherited and he accuses politicians of
selling out to the company said Vidya
quote oops yeah you can feel the
corruption here he says corruption is
one issue but the dangers of mining with
cyanide are larger Romania has already
suffered the consequences
I'm visiting Raoul Morrison he's a
scientist and he's going to show me
photos of another gold mine south of
Russia Montana
there was a cyanide disaster here in the
early 1970s the dam broke here says
Raoul he supports the opponents of the
mind toxic mud flooded the village of
jerash during the communist dictatorship
of Nicolae Ceausescu no one was
permitted to talk about the cyanide
catastrophe in its victims these photos
were found later in secret police
archives I'm driving south toward
jerkish after decades of gold mining
with cyanide this is what the place
looks like today Cheerilee Yohan
survived the disaster he lives at the
site and remembers what happened what's
he about on their cots they were all
drowned in the mud and I couldn't pull
them out he says I tried but I got stuck
in the poisonous mud as well it was
really thick and sticky
the clothes that they'd had on were
practically burned off their bodies they
were naked cyanide and rock mix came
down from the banks up there dahi
Sputnik are gone so dinar oka I'm back
in Russia Montana there were some gold
mining here during communist times I
meet up with Doreen Roose he's one of
the last people employed at the site of
the old communist era mining company but
gold was mined earlier too and he's
showing me the way into what's a museum
now we're heading down to where miners
dug for gold 2,000 years ago
Doreen works mainly as a tourist guide
now and he says the Romans mind clearly
visible veins of gold it's different
it's a little black because of that they
call in vain because you can see in that
human body the vein different from the
human body
nowadays the gold isn't that easy to
find there's only one gram in a ton of
rock the Romans could almost grab gold
with their bare hands 100 years ago
miners used dynamite and now they need
cyanide I've arranged a meeting with
Catalin hosu from the Russia Montana
Gold Mining Corporation
we drive past the wreckage of the
Communist era operations to a disused
mind overlooking the village you put the
rocks in a mill the mill is a horizontal
cylinder with steel balls inside that
will crush the the rock it will crush it
to a very fine powder that way you can
liberate the gold and silver from the
rock by using cyanide which binds the
precious metals the result is a toxic
mixture of old rocks which will be
stored out here in the hills but the
Gold Corporation still wants a green
image and so we visit a water
purification plant after 2,000 years of
mining the bare rock the mountain
streams in Russia Montana look like this
the water has washed out heavy metals
like cadmium what you want to say is
that you're doing an
environmental-friendly project here so
basically yes yes this water all of it
will be tricky but it can have life
fish life there's no life in that stream
at this point the argument over Europe's
largest gold-mining project has turned
into a war of interpretation who says
the Gold Corporation does more good to
they are archeology and they're gonna
join us for the tour will have a tour
and then on our way out we're gonna stop
where the where the miners are work and
for the first time I realize what the
men are doing here while they can't mine
for gold some of them are emptying old
Roman mining shafts occasionally they
turn up some old artifacts like this
ancient wooden ladder it was the wrong
way round when they found it a sign that
there's no more gold in this tunnel
outside again I'm approached by a group
of people you're desperate says this
woman there's no other way of making a
living here apart from mining we always
lived from mining here and we want to
keep on doing so us and our children and
their children please help us
mining isn't like it used to be there
are new technologies I ask if my guy put
them up to this I think I have my doubts
but it's clear that there's a clash of
two very different interest groups in
Russia Montana it's getting late I meet
up again with aunty mining activists
Tudor and Ogun they're not budging
rougane says he doesn't care what they
want to dig for he's only interested in
the fact that they want to make money by
destroying his world God like medieval
Russia but she'll never give back but is
Luciana and whatever happens the
argument over the gold mine shows one
thing at least an environmental
conscience is developing in Romania two
decades after the end of communism